volkswagen presents the seventh
generation of the Golf GTI we check out
the performance edition in southern
France it packs 169 kilowatts of power
no major changes were made to the
outside of the new GTI and why should
there be aficionados know what matters
about their goal so Volkswagen
concentrated on the performance
the progressive steering system results
in a significantly smaller steering
angle that means just over two full
turns from one end stop to the other
as if I'm a race ace hon co-construct
calls the performance sensational you
don't have to turn the wheel that much
going into a bend it's more precise this
is crucial in terms of feedback for the
driver so he can feel the curve better
thick fit in faro damaged mystic by a
dandy covetous of spirit and there's
more the performance is further enhanced
by a front axle differential lock this
is under the cornish understory
THERMOTRONIC it's an electronically
controlled mechanical lock to give the
car even more traction explains VW's
chassis development chief what we've
done is added something innovative to
the car to make the front wheel drive
extra sporty not much focus shots of
Mohandas it's the front axle
differential lock ultimately pulls the
car in the curves while accelerating
octave of mine nikova it's called torque
vector authority under steering you used
to see in front wheel drive cars is
completely compensated here it means the
car holes in the curves wonderful if we
move on the coal behind as well as
upping the performance though the makers
also wanted to make the new GTI more
nimble diggity is that since it's a
compact sports car we had to make the
GTI lights as geese we stripped off 42
kilograms torque is also important we
added 70 Newton meters for a total of
three hundred fifty at the same time we
lowered fuel consumption thing it's now
at six liters for 100 kilometers tomato
and the overall result we can go from 0
to 100 km/h in 6.5 seconds those are the
crucial figures when describing the GTI
the seventh generation is twice the
amount of output as the original GTI the
performance version we tested delivers
169 kilowatts of power
let's compare the original GTI with the
latest edition in the front back then is
now there's the GTI logo
the front lights and indicators now
comprise a single unit and the wing
mirrors have built-in signals to from
the side the GTI looks very aerodynamic
and there's no escaping the famous logo
there either the rear is likewise
unmistakable
thanks to the dual injection system with
both direct and multi-point fuel
injection the GTI fulfills the Euro 6
emission standard that takes effect in
2014 it retains the simple but classic
elegance of the original GTI and the
three-spoke steering wheel is still
around today still a standard feature is
the golf ball style shift knob the check
pattern seats have lost none of their
charm so much for the visual impact of a
new GTI but how does it drive we have a
real expert answer these and other
questions
he give us a racing drivers take on the
front axle differential lock this is
cousin-fucker sock you hit a curve and
notice that the car is getting unsettled
you accelerate the car practically pulls
around the curve by itself because
hydraulic lock engages at the front that
prevents the wheel spinning it's great
I'm it does nt do a thing when a
defender does fancy so Toya doesn't have
my fur via tumblr but choose to make
sure he put the new GTI through its
paces around the famous all recon
circuit
it's immediately apparent that the
differential lock is very useful around
bends the GTI firmly hugs the road
especially at high speeds
350 newton meters of torque Jose to
enhance awoken likes he gets the most
out of the GTI's power particularly
around Kurds he's very impressed
hey thank us outside it's hard to
believe how fast we went around bends
it's incredible when taking curves you
feel totally safe with the steering and
when accelerating absolutely top-notch I
[ __ ] host ecclesia